es el último giro en el tigre y afloje
entre rondes antis y Disney el gigante
el entretenimiento lleva meses en el
punto de mira el gobernador republicano
por criticar una ley del estado de la
Florida que prohíbe hablar de
orientación sexual e identidad de género
en las escuelas
nunca nunca iremos a la multitud
Florida es el lugar donde los morirán el
gobernador potencial candidato a la
presidencia Estados Unidos ha hecho la
lucha contra el vocalismo término para
referirse al progresismo su batalla en
febrero eliminó el estatus especial de
Disney Y puso fin a los beneficios
administrativos y Fiscales del parque
ron de santis también nombró un nuevo
comité para supervisar Su futuro Disney
ha decidido pelearse con este comité no
vamos a buscar pelea pero Disney no está
de acuerdo el parque afirma que es
víctima de una venganza debido a su
posición política considera que se trata
de una violación a su libertad de
expresión y una medida contra Libre
Mercado por lo que interpuso una demanda
sin embargo para ron de santis el
reclamo de Disney no tiene validez No
creo que la demanda tenga mérito creo
que es política creo que se presentaron
en talla por una razón porque están
tratando de generar un de decisión
judicial Pero tenemos mucha confianza en
la ley para la empresa esta denuncia es
una forma de proteger a sus empleados
clientes y socios el grupo anunció
recientemente que quiere crear más de
10.000 puestos de trabajo e invertir
17,000 millones de dólares en Disney
World en los próximos 10 años